[Music]
all right we're doing telling a little
different on the Rubin report today for
the past two years we've sat down one on
one to interview interesting relevant
people finding out what they think and
why they think it every week I also try
to share with you what's on my mind with
an explanation as to why discussing the
ideas of the week is so important one of
the things that we promised you when we
launched on patreon last year was that
when we hit the 30k a month mark we'd
start expanding the show in new ways
such as hosting debates and doing more
live streams well just last week we did
three live streams with Carl Benjamin
aka sargon of akkad Tim pool and Maajid
Nawaz this week we're going to host our
first debate we aren't quite at that 30k
mark yet but we wanted to offer this up
as a tease of what's to come and show
you that our commitment to bringing you
new engaging content is as strong as
ever so joining me today are two former
guests of the Rubin report and more
importantly two people that I'm proud to
call my friend Dennis Prager is a
conservative radio host and author of
several best-selling books Michael
Shermer is the founding publisher of
skeptic magazine and also the author of
several best-selling books I find both
of them to be engaging interesting and
unafraid to share their personal and
political views about three months ago
Dennis did a video for his YouTube
channel Prager you in which he made the
case that without God there is no
objective truth to tell us murder isn't
wrong a few days later Michael made a
follow-up video on why he believes that
you can indeed have morality without God
Michael's response to Dennis was
respectful and thoughtful and I thought
that it opened a door for us to have a
conversation about one of the most
fundamental issues about what it means
to be human and to live a good life so
without further ado I present you our
first Reuben report conversation not
debate but conversation we're two guests
who hold deeply held opposing beliefs
but who I know will be honest decent and
respectful at the same time here we go
[Music]
all right guys I'm thrilled to be doing
this today because I am sitting here
between two men that I totally respect
but more importantly I consider friends
that I have broken bread with that I've
just spent time in the green room
chatting with so first let's do some
intro is here is Dennis Prager to my
right Michael Shermer to my left and
we're going to do something a little
different today a little different than
I normally do I've had both of you on
the show before we've talked about your
ideas and let you say what you think
about things and today we're gonna have
a discussion on something that you guys
feel very differently about but I think
can do it in a respectful honest and
decent way we're going to be talking
about morality and God something that
both of you have written a lot about you
did a Prager you video about three
months ago and that's what sort of
kicked off the idea for this
conversation and before we do anything
even even about the video and even
putting morality and God aside for a
second I thought we should start first
by just three people sitting in a room
that are okay disagreeing on some stuff
it has become incredibly rare the idea
that you guys have a totally different
view on something that's really one of
the most existential questions that
there is but we were all just hanging
out out there and your wife's here and
my parents are out there and we were all
everyone was chatting and laugh and have
a good time and this has become almost
an endangered species of an idea so
let's just start there why do you think
this has happened I know the reason but
I'm afraid to say it because it's it
will sound like I'm just a political
advocate but I have no choice I believe
that it is virtually entirely a product
of the left and Mike I could prove it I
truly believe it's provable I have I
have an acronym six herb sexist
intolerant xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic racist bigoted if you
differ with anyone from the New York
Times I'm not talking about crackpot
left normal left
if you differ with them you are bad
you're not wrong you are bad and that's
that's the origin we don't have that we
do not have a sick Serb conservatives
don't have a list of adjectives that are
comparable and and and that's why I
attribute it to the left
see how he buttered me up to start us on
right going right to my wheelhouse
niya Davis continues himself a
conservative you're sort of a
libertarian if we had to give you a
label that we labels are always
problematic today I'll have in their
mind what they think that is like Oh Ron
Paul no wait a minute I don't agree with
everything with classical liberal I like
and I was glad to see you you know kind
of throw that back into the ring is
that's a label that's we should all be
using I like that yeah but what do you
think has happened to conversation I
know both of you guys by the way you do
actually do this you debate people in a
respectful way I'm considering this more
of a conversation and a debater I'm not
scoring this thing at the end right I'm
not announcing a winner but what do you
think has happened to that because even
debates these days with with people that
are pretty well known and and you know
big authors and things have sort of
devolved into I think what Dennis is
talking about where person what do they
well I think I think in part I think
dennis is put is largely correct it's
more from the left and the right
certainly and in the Academy I think it
evolved from the 60s emphasis on the use
of language and how certain words are
toxic and caused people to think
differently and so you start for
something like the n-word let's stop
using that okay and things like use his
in her rather than always his alright
you know these are small things but
maybe that you know okay so they kind of
get you to comment kind of go along with
some of that you know like I've wrote
about Sam bozos you know how they like
Sambo's they have the images of the
little black kid it's like okay that's
no longer cool and we've all kind of
made that transition and most of its
reasonable but then you start you know
cascading along the spectrum to like
every word you say every phrase the way
you turn it microaggressions you know
there's no evidence at all that
microaggressions cause harm there's not
been a single study biological science I
think
I've been studies saying that it doesn't
actually I think I don't even came out
this week that's right yeah yeah so so
it just kind of caught on is an idea
that's kind of a political movement idea
that they've got absorbed by the left so
the left's argument is that ok so words
matter words can hurt then all of a
sudden words are violence and therefore
it's ok to commit violence against
somebody who uses words wait a minute
when did that happen
right and this is this is this concept
of punching Nazis which I've been saying
you cannot punch the road right over an
idea ok so so one other thing before we
get into the meat of this but the crux
of this is is basically that you are a
believer and that you are not a believer
so well that's not the crooks forgive me
but I take it away oh no III don't think
it is because I have debated atheists
like at Oxford many years ago and it's
in print and it's on the internet so one
could see it
the professor Jonathan Jonathan Glover
who's an atheist and a professor moral I
think world philosophy then at Oxford
now at another British University the
first thing he said when we debated was
I agree with mr. Prager if there is no
God ethics is subjective so and there
are people who believe in God who agree
with Michael that it's whether or not
there's a God is is is important
obviously but still ethics are
subjective no matter what or you can
have objective ethics without God so the
fact that he's not a believer and I am a
believer is not fully dispositive ok
that that's a fair critique and you
actually mention that in your in your
video that you get up on paper you
that's wrong as you say that exact thing
so ok I'll rephrase it a little bit and
just say you are a believer and you are
not a believer fair right or fair okay
correct so then I just want to ask one
other thing and then we're going to jump
in were you always a believer and where
does that come from within you well I I
was all I was raised in a religious
Jewish home an Orthodox Jewish home I I
didn't stay Orthodox but I stayed
religious but ironically and I do write
about this elsewhere you could again on
the internet how I found God at Columbia
the truth is that
this is will sound odd but the biggest
single factor in moving me to believe in
God has been the secular foolishness
that has permeated our society I was
taught at Columbia's a prestigious place
by very bright secular often
non-believers and I was taught mostly
nonsense and I remember I went crazy
thinking why is there so much nonsense
being taught at an Ivy League university
by bright people then a phrase from the
Bible came into my brain in Hebrew and
it's very well known to people who've
studied the Bible you will know the
phrase certainly and that is wisdom
begins with fear of God and then I
realized Wow no God no wisdom and that
has that has permit permeated my life in
other words it is the the anti God crowd
that has made me realize how important
God is that's it's not God didn't appear
to me the religious have not convinced
me
if the irreligious have convinced me of
the centrality of God to the world for
that anything you didn't have the
burning bush no no I had the opposite I
had a frozen bush yeah yes yes I
actually mentioned on a few weeks ago on
the show I did hike Mount Sinai myself
and I was ready I mean I was about 21
and I was ready to see a burning bush
and I hiked at the wrong time of day so
I was you know dripping with sweat and I
had eaten some bad pigeon in Egypt so I
was having some stomach problems on the
holiest mountain out of my feet and and
nothing nothing happened when I got up
there and I really was ready so for you
I mean I know this I'm leaving a little
bit but were you always a non-believer
where did this come yes I was raised in
a largely secular home my parents were
not religious neither were they anti
religious for atheists or it just never
came up and you know when I was around
the 50s and 60s that wasn't a thing like
you know what's your religious visit are
you an atheist you know atheism wasn't
even
really to be so but when I went to high
school and then in college you know the
born-again movement was kind of taking
off so I became a born-again in high
school in 1971 I went to Pepperdine
University with the Church of Christ
school very conservative at the time and
and I was pretty serious about it I mean
I took all the Bible classes the Old
Testament the New Testament the life of
Christ the writings of CS Lewis I've
read everything he's either it written
and so forth and then and I went door to
door because if you're an evangelical by
definition you're supposed to evangelize
that's what you do so you know Amway
with Bibles yeah I did it and and I I
liked doing it and and then when I
became when I kind of gave that up I
wasn't really a militant atheist because
again that wasn't really a thing in the
late 70s and early 80s when I sort of
dropped my religious beliefs and you
know and said that brings us to this
point that a theism isn't really a thing
to be it's just a lack of belief
full-stop so what do you believe you
know science and reason and civil
liberties and civil rights and equal
treatment and all these kind of lighten
mminton Lichtman humanism or whatever
classical liberalism you know those are
the things I believe in I don't believe
in atheism because it isn't a worldview
it's just sure I don't believe it God
pull stop now what so then it becomes
okay so are those values that you
believe in equal treatment under the law
of women's rights gay rights civil
liberties right and wrong you know is
killing his murder wrong yes I believe
they're real and you believe they're
real so the question then is well what's
the source
right and that basically brings us to
you for that I'm doing this video yes I
have a question for you and then it's
not a trick or nothing I'm very curious
it's and I say oh and you you know I
think you've heard my show on a few
occasions and I so we're gonna get down
here yes absolutely yourself no no IIIi
why not by music you know why not listen
to me why not have you on my show okay
so I say I now say I've written on this
the life like the question I most want
an answer to most curious to get events
do from an atheist do you hope you're
right or do you hope you're wrong
I don't really hope I just sort of go
along and just try to lead a good life
and I'm not hoping for anything really I
mean if it turned out there's a god yes
would you be would you be happy I mean
are there people there undoubtedly
people you love in your life so if there
is a God and the traditional belief is
an afterlife you would have you would
reconnect sure and I we had I would be
glad about my horse okay that's all okay
let me tell why I am yes that would be
the reason if that was the the version
that was real you know to mean people
well if God is good there's an afterlife
if God is an idiot or God is cool or God
doesn't give a damn about his creation
then there's no afterlife but on the I
make only two leaps of faith it's all I
make that that God exists that God as
the creator and God is good and if
that's the case then there's an
afterlife that's all you can't have a
good God and this totally unjust world
be the only existence that that would be
a cruel God that's all that weren't in
death and the only reason by the way I
asked it is because and I'm happy you
did that because I respect you as you
know and and I'm always puzzled if an
atheist doesn't answer well of course it
would be nice or of course I'd like it
it doesn't it doesn't undermine your
position in the least I think it gives
you credibility that in other words
against your your desire nevertheless
your mind has reasoned out there is no
God which isn't that completely
consistent but with the things you
believe because sort of that you have a
curious mind so that you found out at
the end that it was a little different
than perhaps you thought I would be
curious to know how was it done you know
and what is it that actually happens in
the subject my next book heavens on
earth it that you know so I talked about
the idea of uploading the mind into a
computer you know copying all your
memories and you get to live forever or
it how is that different really from God
pulling you up out of the grave what's
he pulling up because most religions
believe you know the body stays in the
grave and the soul or the copy of you
goes to heaven well if it's a copy of me
then it's not really me and so what's
actually going on there I'd be curious
to know how that works if that's the
case and also I do have some issues
about heaven though I mean
boring I mean the turn journey is a long
time especially near the end is in and
and you know as hitch famously said
heaven would be like celestial North
Korea I don't want a dictator that knows
every one of my thoughts so this can't
be I'm thinking of it as a human that
can't be what heaven would be like but I
don't actually even know Dennis what
what we're talking right I don't either
I only know that a good God has figures
out how to undo the terrible injustice
of this life that's it I'm curious I
wasn't planning on even asking this but
would you both concede that the other
one could be right of course he could be
right obviously I would only say I
intellectually this has obviously none
of you would Michael I have great
respect for intellectually I respect
agnosticism more than atheism the the
certitude that that implies
I don't intellectually quite understand
it's like I don't understand a believer
who never has doubts I don't get it so I
don't understand an atheist who never
has doubt that's a fair critique because
we hear that a lot of it that's right
these days I think we hear it more
unusual - clarification on the terms
yeah agnostic technically when Huxley
coined the term he meant unknowable not
like you're waiting there for one more
experiment or one more piece of data and
then I'll make up my mind he said it's
just not knowable in any you know
rational scientific sense and I and so
on - logically speaking I'm an agnostic
we can't know there's no experiment
we're going to run it there it is you
know point oh five levels significance
gods exist right atheist so there's
strong and weak atheism so starting
atheism I know there's no God that to me
is an indefensible position so we can
see is imide just don't believe in a God
it could be wrong you know that that's
the more defensible position yeah that
would be my position and I think that's
sort of consistent yes yeah well more so
obviously the earth I I mean there's not
obviously the subject but it doesn't
matter it's a greatest I like anyway I I
intellectually not emotionally not
religiously I don't get how someone can
look at the universe and think it came
about on its own
I debated the Lawrence Krauss on the
show so you know who said something from
nothing
yeah so what a given positive faith I
said so what is nothing they said well
nothing is something and I have you know
how respectfully I treat people I differ
with because because you've been on the
show a number of times yeah and I was
respectful but I did say something to
the effect ah you know I'm now entering
a sort of voodoo land if some if nothing
is something then nothing isn't nothing
you can't have it both ways
couldn't you uphold some sort of
rabbinical something out I probably yes
if it turns on how what we mean by these
words you know so when a physicist like
Lawrence Krauss talks about nothing he
doesn't mean it in the same way say a
theologian might say nothing because
there is no nothing in physics there's
always some energy field a quantum foam
field something like this that things
pop out of like photons of light don't
exist and they pop out of nothing in
atoms so this art this already happened
something comes from nothing that all
physicists agree oh that's how like is
formed ok so why can't a university this
is Laura's argument so when he says
nothing he means you know something
different and I think at some point we
kind of hit an epistemological wall when
we talk about things like nothing
eternity
you know infinity you know we as finite
beings that are in a three-dimensional
world four-dimensional we can't really
know what those words mean on some say
cosmic sense yeah something outside of
us do you think that could be just the
great existential question of being a
human that we simply you know we're
going to do it we'll do this we can go
for hours if you want if we can have you
guys clear out your evenings and do
dinner here too but we're going to be
like a certain amount there's a certain
amount of people in between right that
may go you know Prager is making a
little sense and it'll move me that way
or sure is Mengele sensing movie that
way but that most people at a certain
point lies you can't get them to move
too far right that's why I just I fully
admit I don't
I don't quite understand seeing the
universe and concluding that on rational
grounds just rational logical grounds
this all came from nothing and that all
the design I see implies no designer I
debated the head of American Atheists
they were wonderful group by the way
they and I always say they gave me the
check that day I had a lot of religious
crap so I just want to be clear with
this David Silverman I don't recall the
name of I feel bad but they had their
annual convention in Minneapolis and I
debated their head and I looked at the
audience at one point and just it just
struck me to ask them I it was very
spontaneous I said how many of you
please raise your hand if you have ever
doubted your atheism and now one hand
went up so they maybe were afraid to
raise their hand alright that's Paula
which is an interesting point action but
because I made the point I said look
when a child is born with terrible
deformity every believer I know goes
where's God we answer but so when a
child is born perfectly formed why
doesn't the atheist go wow that's that's
Depp it doesn't seem that it's
completely random
well not random it's still a WoW moment
for all of us well no wow but it's a
random well not not random so it says
well it's either design or Ram no no so
the forces of nature and on random that
you know the emergent property of
complexity comes from simplicity by the
laws of nature themselves it's built
into the system and you can ask what
were the laws of matrix yes well I would
ask you do a study you still have the
same problem with the infinite regress
argument that if you say well God did it
well where did God come from well God is
that which does not need to be created
well why can't the University that which
does not because the universe is
physical and God is better well there
could be a pre-existing state you know
again we you know we can only push back
so far to the you know the way you can
only push back so far within the
physical universe but but the I
at something outside of the physical
realm made the physical realm is more
coherent to me than the physical realm
made itself well but but there could be
multiple universes okay that's not later
okay there I that's where you lose me
also that the Dave Rubin show is
happening just like this because there's
an infinite number you run or not that
kind of multiple universe not a letter
show than this itself that's a tough
thing but so that arguments you that's
the same thing as the Kraus argument
right like you mean a multiple universe
yes the mobile year it's a cop-out no no
no no there's a he knows better than I
because he knows more science than I you
cannot possibly ever there will not not
possible for us to it it kept contact or
proven of the universe be so it's it's a
it's a statement made that has less
argument for it than the belief in God
yeah well I don't think he said it was
provable I know he didn't say it but but
even offering it as an argument if
that's you if that's your argument then
I have a good sound argument okay it's
it's not quite the argument so first of
all dispense with the multiple universes
where we're sitting here in another
studio some yeah you know I don't go for
that okay but there but the idea that
there could be an eternal sequence or
cycles of universes you know kind of a
Buddhist sort of thing or in do sort of
thing or all the way up to what you know
there's a half a dozen of these physical
theories that are put forth by
businesses they're not met they're not
like oh I'm an atheist I got to come up
with something that's not what they're
doing they're making predictions based
on the mathematical principles of the
universe and how these laws of nature's
could come about and so on they may all
be wrong they may never even be tested
we don't know and that's perfectly OK in
science to throw those kinds of things
out there and see what happens maybe the
gravitational wave research now that's
all the thing that that may be able to
detect colliding universes from you know
that cause these gravity ways to treat
something like that is possible but now
but that could make it testable at the
moment is not testable so both of us end
up at an epistemological wall where we
can't go any further and then that we're
just using words well God is that which
does not need to be created as outside
of space and time okay these are just
words were using we don't know that no I
don't know that I
it makes more sense than the physical
world and everything in it you and I
both love music you know so there is no
appoint boss who I'm sure you adore a
box entually the father of Western clubs
may be the best argument for God's
existence by the way is Bobby yes that's
why I'm using that hand and I'll see
that manager playing the violin right
and he wrote on every one of his
manuscripts for the greater glory of God
so you hear this stuff and and you so
we've gone from photons to BA and and
that's designed but there's no designer
why that strikes you is more logical is
my puzzle well okay so the derivative of
complex ideas from simpler ideas and
from big brains from smaller brains you
can see the gradation and evolution so
the chip can't do Buck the dog can't do
Bach or morality for that matter so the
reason we're different than say lions
killing something and why we would call
it murder in the lion would is because
we have brains big enough capable of
conceiving of morality
music mathematics logic poetry and so on
and that is special wherever sources
it's that we all recognize it as being
transcendently special so we we've done
about 20 minutes and we haven't really
really mentioned morality or or what or
what the purpose of your original video
was in your country now I watch them
both again this morning because I really
wanted to have them fresh in my mind and
I and I kind of struggled with how
exactly I was going to frame this
because I thought well maybe if I just
go off your video that would be the
right way because you did the counter
video then I thought maybe I need to
bounce back and forth between a few
things so I'm going to bounce around I
have a feeling that I've got two people
of intellect that can follow me here so
so one of the things that you talked
about so let's shift this into morality
God and and murder so you talk about
scientific facts verse moral facts and I
think people can probably figure out
what that means but but can you just
explain that concept again
well the I think everyone can understand
and I I'm not saying to the
condescending way that if you don't
agree with me you're not on my level of
understanding but I think it's axiomatic
that you can't learn morality from
nature nature especially if you believe
in the survival of the fittest if that's
your guideline and that was a guideline
for people like Hitler that he actually
did say that but even dropping any
reference to a given mass murderer their
science doesn't tell me to be honorable
science doesn't tell me to to do
anything against my self-interest The
Selfish Gene written by an atheist that
we are we're composed of selfish genes
you need you need a mind and you need I
believe an outside source to say this is
what is right this is what is wrong
because science doesn't tell you that
that's all it's not it's not a that's
not I don't even think that's debatable
how do I know not not to steal because
of atoms or or or biology I don't think
you do well your moral conscience tells
you that and where did that come from
okay so let's pull back for a second so
your video opened up is murder wrong
okay what is murders let's define some
terms here to get us some clarification
murder is the wrongful killing of one
human by another so it's like asking is
wrong wrong yes it's right there in the
word so maybe we mean is killing wrong
no no we men is murder I meant this
murder royalty by definition is it's
like yes I definitely yes by definition
but but that's not the issue my video is
not is is why is Berta wrong not whether
it is wrong yeah why is it right yeah
why is it wrong because we've defined it
that way okay but they so my argument
yes that my argument is that's the whole
point if we've defined it that way then
we are God and we could say murder
murder blacks murder Jews murder gays
right no no because of okay so two
things one first of all if you say that
well it's God that told told us that
it's wrong
you know all right so first of all did
God have reasons for why murder is wrong
or is he just randomly declaring this
and that wrong or right
my guess is you'd say he had reasons and
so the question is what are those
reasons and why not skip the divine
middleman and just base our moral
reasoning on those reasons that we too
can come up with moral reasoning because
well I wish it worked because my bottom
line is I just want people to do good
yes if a theist I'm much closer to a
good atheist and a bad religious person
so my bottom line is goodness but I that
a very young age that reason doesn't
take me to goodness reason is a tool
reason is a hammer
hammers build hospitals and hammers
build torture chambers yeah so a reason
does reason is great but it doesn't give
you the gold reason gives you the means
but even but but the pull back how do
you know that mark murder is wrong from
from the divine command there in your
perspective I mean you said you don't
talk to gut you know you're not right I
believe in Revelation I do believe the
Ten Commandments were revealed okay so
again so you know as you know Plato
refuted this argument 2500 years ago if
God is just declaring things randomly
then then if he if he didn't say murder
was wrong would that make it okay well
to us to be to be a consistent it would
be but he didn't do that so it's
irrelevant it's like you know there's an
old year saying if my you know my
grandmother had balls she'd be my
grandfather
yeah okay so this is not an if that that
matters is it turns out that moral
reasoning and what God is dictating seem
to coincide very often but that's not a
issue remember my issue is beyond what
we're speaking about there is no
forgetting murder for a moment there is
no good and evil if there is no God
there are only opinions about good and
evil just like Beauty do you think
there's an objective beauty I think
there's a basis to it yes what does that
mean does it evolved propensity to
prefer some characteristics in people
and land all right but it doesn't make
something beautiful about it
okay but but what do you mean by
objective objective that it has just
this objectively this Cup this this
glass exists so it's not just it's not
my you know my opinion as a wreck I so I
think I think moral values actually have
a factual basis that are like the glass
a little more complicated but based on
our human nature - so you mentioned The
Selfish Gene we do have our inner demons
that cause us to want to be selfish and
greedy and avarice and so forth but we
also have our better angels that is it
pays to be cooperative nice altruistic
and caring and loving for other human
beings particularly those in your tribe
and and it benefits yourself as jeans to
be nice to other people now immediately
in your in your immediate family
standard family and your community and
studies show this does pay off now
unfortunately we're very tribal to other
people who may be threatening our
empathetic notions about our fellow
beings but that's involved
characteristic we can see it in primates
and children and so on there's a deep
sense from the moment you're born of
there's a right and a wrong and and that
comes from this evolved propensity to
survive in a social community you can't
survive by murdering cheating lying and
so forth and so that's where it comes
from and I consider that to be
transcendent of you and me it's not my
opinions not your opinion it belongs to
the species we're born that way lions
don't have that chimps don't quite have
that like we have it and so on does this
there's a you know a scale of this so
one of my favorite videos from prawns of
all is the two little like capuchin
monkeys that are each taught to swap a
pebble for a grape or a cucumber slice
so it's the pebbles are like money so
they so you see this video or the
experimenter gives the one a pebble he
gives it back and he gets a cucumber
slice eats and he's happy then the other
one does the same thing and he gets a
grape now they like grapes better than
cucumbers because who doesn't and and so
the other one the first one sees that he
goes oh boy I'm going to get a grape and
he runs and gets his pebble and he puts
the tough when the experimenter gives a
few cover slides and each plate and you
see in me throws it at the experimenter
he's pounding on
Cady's rattling the cage wall he is
pissed because that guy got something I
didn't get that was not right I did the
same amount of work that he did and he
got something so you can see that sense
they don't have language they can't call
it anything but they have a sense of
wrong I was wrong that was okay so let
me respond that experiment does not show
what you just said that experiment shows
that he's pissed on his behalf you find
me one monkey on the face of the earth
that rattles the cage because the other
guy was wrong then I will take that
argument series actually this is
completely selfish base number two you
mentioned children so you have raised I
know that not yes it is selfish base but
it's about what's right and wrong baby
for me no no no no it's not about right
and wrong it's about me
I feel gypped that doesn't count but
they don't rattle cages on behalf of
other one down it's a sense of fairness
like I want what's right for me yes for
me and then what I know well what's
right for you fair but what does it take
for us to scale up to for me to care
about what's right for me to care about
what's right for you it takes
transcendent morality it doesn't take
celebration to take children you
mentioned children here the idea that we
could learn that children are born with
a strong moral sense
I mean you've read Lord of the Flies I
think that's far more accurate let me
just ask you a question you raised a
child right and I'm so I just want to
ask you how many times do you feel
roughly you told her say thank you
ten thousand nine I've not that many
times I know you just have to imagine a
little bit not them a little bit all
please but there are waters the real
white high child in hell I told I told
my son's at each of them at least ten
thousand times they like say thank you
if they were inherently good they would
first of all never have to be told the
first is not and certainly not many
other times not black and white it's all
they're all good or they're all evil no
no no no but the only way we can learn
that we have this great we built-in
sense dude why did the world stay they
read pow world is unfilled why slavery
universal rape universal murder
universal well we know even this is
rarer than than all
the IRA lies but but it's been changing
and there's a reason for that and the
reason is reason ever since the
Enlightenment we've been changing the
conditions of society politics economics
and social systems to emphasize the
better angels and squish you know sort
of attenuate the the inner demons we
know how to do this it's sort of like a
behavioral game matrix like okay we're
going to in crochet we had this debate
200 years ago right before the right
before the Enlightenment you would have
agreed with me I thought we would have
been religious and we probably would
have been on the same well on
pro-slavery and so forth well I do think
this is an interesting point because
when I had you on just a couple months
ago and you were arguing for morality
through a judeo-christian value a lot of
people were saying to me he's actually
just arguing for enlightenment values
which I thought well I think so I think
that's the key oh no no I think you're
but I've been influenced by the
Enlightenment
pretty much III can answer you I having
been raised in my specification which is
probably it's truly irrelevant to the
point but in my specific case I assure
you I was raised in an Orthodox Jewish
Melia Oh half the day Hebrew studies in
Hebrew of the Bible and the Talmud and
so on and half of a secular studies I if
I would have said to one of my rabbis
from Eastern Europe the French
enlightenment he would have he would
have looked around and you know was that
the name of a new I don't know well not
not rock group he didn't know a lot but
anyway he would have thought maybe it
was a food French enlightenment right
but that might have showed the
limitations of his thinking though yes I
agree with you but that's not the point
the point is what influenced me more I
don't I don't know I I believe that God
wanting to me good God demands that I be
good is the single most animating a
thing in my life and I want it to be the
most animating thing in everybody's life
I don't trust people who listen to their
inner voice a handful of occasions it
will work for the vast majority of
people the inner voice will be if
if a young man can get away with
grabbing a woman the inner voice will be
dwarfed by his testosterone so all right
so that it's a good segue to two things
so first I just want to jump back to the
monkey yes sample yeah in a second
because do you think it's possible that
if they kept doing that experiment over
time the monkey who was seeing his
friend be wronged would eventually start
because there is on behalf of the monkey
because that doesn't I think that would
strengthen that argument I don't know
that thing okay so it's a frog's vols
research shows that you can nudge it in
that direction not very far so he does
research with elephants and you know
other mammals and you can get them just
you can see that they start to care for
the other individual if they're being
harmed like like they're getting
electric shocks if they do something
that sacrifices themselves to stop the
electric shock right but you use a belay
than the cucumber the day a monkey
starts rattling the cage because his
friend got a cucumber ape but I will be
impressed yes okay okay and then also
read Paul blooms book just babies so
they show that like these little things
of the infant they can't speak yet okay
so but they're doing these little puppet
things and they have a puppet show or
the one puppet is trying to push this
ball up a ramp and another puppet comes
in and pushes them back down and he
fails or the other one the other puppet
comes up and helps him right so then
they show the babies they get it to pick
which puppet they like the most and they
always like the one that helped right
and and and so Bloom's got these great
videos where you can see a lot of times
these little babies will reach out and
slap that the bad puppet you know it's
like that that puppet puppet was bad so
this is said like six months a year old
year and a half they already have a
sense of that's right and that's wrong
helping is good harming is not good okay
now so we don't need to go from there to
say well that how do you explain evil
it's in there
we have inner demons we also have that I
think why I think that's true I think
that there were good you might say well
God God put it in there but to get back
to my earlier point how do you know
so you said revelation but you you mean
they wrote the Bible the Old Testament
okay so so but other religious leaders
like the leader of Isis you know Baghdad
he says I get revelation from I know
what's right and right well I have an
answer to that I have an answer like
here
curious to hear your answer because I've
heard this a lot in it's a it's a
plausible argument how do you know which
God for them okay if if I came along and
I and I developed a brown bubbly drink
and said this is Coca Cola and you would
say well there really is a real Coca
Cola you are making up something new
well beyond EFT chronologically the
original coca-cola it's your recipe it
doesn't taste like it it doesn't look
like it and you don't have the same
ingredients but you're calling it
coca-cola God was introduced to humanity
by the old testament that everybody
acknowledges all right that's the God
I'm talking about if there are
variations on that theme that's their
business there is a coca-cola and I'm
talking about coca-cola I'm talking
about the God given to humanity through
the Old Testament that God gave the Ten
Commandments in my view and that made
murder absolutely wrong not dependent
upon personal or societal opinion and
what what about right before that right
before that happened they're waiting for
me for four to both days before there
were a lot of people who thought murder
was wrong I have the course that's true
but it wasn't objectively wrong it was
subjectively wrong and there's a big
difference I am now telling you God says
that the that killing wrongly is
absolutely wrong there is an objective
morality here which a commandment are
you talking about into six so this is
thou shalt not kill no murder
if the Hebrew any English are learn
about it but again back to my original
point by definition it's wrong I know
we're talking about knowing but but
wrongful killing right wrongful killer
son killing is okay who says yes of
course that's true some sex is okay some
sex is rape right that's true about
every action all right so how much of
this then to you is the micro verse the
macro because I sense you're actually
conceding a little bit of ground in that
you don't think that Michael is going to
murder anyone but that you think that
for society as a whole so that his
eighth
right because Haiti ISM is okay what I
said dividing them or what is the legal
statement bed bed cases or exceptional
cases make bad law whatever it is I of
course there will be individuals look my
favorite analogy seatbelts save lives is
that a generalization it is true is it
true in every single case of course not
sometimes you die because you wore a
seatbelt a choke view you couldn't get
out of a burning car or whatever so do
if there are two people one they're both
moral Michael Shermer is moral this
guy's moral the guy who thinks God will
judge him for his behavior
I trust in the final analysis more then
the person who only has to answer to his
own conscience I am NOT a big believer
in humanity unless the guy says a lot
bar just before you're right right
that's not that's not the God I'm
talking about it so what is it we had an
Iman here so then all right so fine so
then I'll give you some out Sato was an
atheist
I didn't saddle to you with Mao Mao
killed eighty million people
well nothing to address that in your
video don't you that they had replaced
with religion was a different yes was an
atheist religion of course yeah but
that's what that is religion I noticed I
was an atheist religion was but but
that's not people don't kill anime
theism the killer name of some ideology
whatever right or racist or I understand
that doesn't matter though you've not
anyway with God and I found if you
believe in God now kill you I don't want
to sell you with the ISIS thing I'm just
saying if we had an imam here and he
said well we believe in revelation also
and ours came in the seventh century and
and you know yes that's fine okay well
I'm telling you that the the God that
you and I are talking about was revealed
in the Old Testament that's the God
we're talking about that another man
makes another claim may he live and be
well it is irrelevant to my argument of
it okay there are people who believe God
God has you know twelve heads and as a
turtle I can't deal with that I'm just
dealing with the God who gave the Ten
Commandments okay but so that though how
then do you square the people I mean
remove the three monotheistic religions
and I'm not
the guy that believes in eternal the
twelve head but just other religious
just other you know polytheistic
religions that have existed for a long
time that do have a basis in Morales
Buddhism yeah who you know and I think
it's terrific where they I don't I don't
think that the Buddha would have argued
that morality is objectively real I I've
studied Buddhism I'm not a Buddhism
scholar but that anyway he he sought
inner enlightenment the Buddhist project
is not to make the world moral it is to
have the individual transcend his ego
and this great value in that but it's a
different aim so what do you think about
the Microverse macro yes I I know I know
you pretty well and I'm pretty sure this
thing's not going to end with you murder
well I think there's I do think there's
some legitimacy to the argument that on
a societal whole it everyone just starts
listening to the thing in there or
people are kind of whack more and
they're going to do crazy things there
we have evidence because we've already
just mentioned Isis and all kinds of it
that's right what do you think about
that yeah the small you know the
individual radical act analysis it's a
perfect point so you and I are both fans
of the founding fathers and the
Constitution and so on and I was just we
were just talking about the Hamilton
biography and what a genius this guy was
Jefferson and so on I don't think they
were channeling Moses or Jesus of the
Old Testament they were channeling
Hobbes Locke and Rousseau era style all
the great philosophers who came before
that thought what's the best way to a
structure society that we attenuate the
inner demons and accentuate the better
angels all right we need you know three
structures you know three judicial sorry
branch of the very branches of
governments are it real really use them
anymore that we need the you know we
need you know we needed the Supreme
Court and we need local court we need a
rule of law we need a police military so
basically all that was a sort of a
science or technology of social
structure how can we do this because
people will act on their own best
self-interest that's why we need checks
and balances and so on and and that
didn't happen in very many places in the
world and historically you know only a
couple of times does that happen so it's
a unique experiment in a way the social
contract let's call it that is a
transcendent objective for
of moral legal social system by which
we're going to live so that we all
flourish and survive and flourish and
have a more moral lives and and it works
pretty well even though like in your
seatbelt example doesn't always work but
it works better than all the other
systems and to me to me it feels
transcendent in the sense it's not my
opinion it's not your opinion you know
these guys set this up it's been tweaked
and tweaked and tweaked it's like an
experiment you know that's why Jefferson
called what we're doing an experiment a
lot we're running the experiment tweak
the variables have another election
tweak the variables the Supreme Court
says now we're going to do this that
let's change that that to me feels
objective in the sense of it's outside
of me and you it's not just opinion all
right I don't know why it feels
objective because they were opinions
they were great opinions we both adore
these people but they were opinions I
just have to take issue though that and
this this one is not in this country and
everything else we spoke about this not
an opinion issue this is is a factual
question and I just factually disagree
every single one of the founders except
for Thomas Paine was a god-centered
person who believed that without God the
American experiment would not work
Washington said it in his famous
inaugural address indoors farewell
address I should say where you're a pair
of raising and he is a full fool who
thinks that we can have a moral Society
without religion Jefferson wrote the the
Declaration of Independence we are
endowed by our Creator because if the
Creator doesn't endow us with
inalienable rights there are in the Navy
noble rights well of course as you know
Jefferson was a deist not really a no
but a deist in those days is not what
these theists today means you believe
that a creator in that end of the issue
they all believed in a providential God
who interfered in human events Benjamin
Franklin in his autobiography wrote I
believe in a God who works in history
and who judges all people and in a
Harrier Hereafter
Franklin and I have the same exact
theology he wasn't an Orthodox Christian
most of them were not that's true but
they were all God centered and the
God was the god of of the of the Bible
so you can separate that sort of God
centered view that they had from the
fact that they very clearly wanted
separation of church and state but I'm
reassured that the overreaching power
not only what they kind of they had but
they had a bigger fear in a society that
would abandon God is the root of of
rights and and human worth that was
there that was as big a fear as any
by the way separation of church and
state as I am we all know what it's
worth just noting is in one letter that
Jefferson wrote it's not in the
Constitution or anything else actually
when my favorite moments in the in the
Hamilton biography is where he later
asked how come he didn't put God in the
Federalist Papers in the Constitution
and he said I forgot okay now the
biographer goes this from a man who
never forgot anything he didn't forget
it because it's not an argument you
can't make you can't make an argument to
your fellow politicians or whatever
you're trying to carry it was the
supposition of the founders that people
would believe that that rights came from
religion and that the Bible would be the
moral educated to love their children
Lincoln would rarely went to church had
a Bible on his nightstand and everyone
says he read it every day well why do
you think they put in and dad by our
Creator oh do you think it was just sort
of a linguistic trick in a way to I I
think it's language they put in just to
kind of reinforce the point like putting
in god we trust' on the money which was
done to in the 50s to counter the
atheism of communism and I think also to
your point I think there was a sense in
the founding fathers that we can't
police everybody it's a big open country
we can't have you know policemen on
every corner and so on it would be good
if everyone had an internal policeman
exactly I totally agree with that I
think we need that anymore in the sense
that okay now we're better people are
kinder today I'll absolutely well I
write the American experiment is
unraveling I don't think so
okay fine you have more optimism about
what ideas well I'm sure you should be
super optimistic the Republicans are
running the show
yeah what about you have bigger fears
related to your media well
okay look all I know is a 50% of kids
according to Pew do not believe in free
speech for Haiti I think that's a
problem where we are is Ray on it oh
yeah I know I agree that's my point yet
I think that the American Revolution is
being undone equality is supplanting
Liberty the French Revolution is
defeating the American Revolution all
right you know what let's hold that to
the end because I think that's where we
can all sort of come around and tie this
nicely together so but just circling
back cuz I'm glad you brought it to the
to the political part of this when I see
all these people on the right that often
talk about God publicly you know
politicians let's say Ted Cruz or
something he'll also say you know I'm a
constitutional conservative and I'm an
absolutist now I believe that the
Constitution is probably the greatest
political document ever made I wish we
could be governed by those three
branches of government that we're
supposed to be I wish we were doing
things the way that they are written
unfortunately we're not for a series of
reasons but do you think that so you
just don't think that that would be
enough I don't would not be enough and
the founders would have said it's not
enough to that's that's my point it's
not it's my opinion obviously but I
believe it was their opinion too they
understood that human nature is so
anarchic that without believing that I
am morally responsible to a moral god
the work the society will fall apart and
I think they're right I would prefer to
believe that people can internalize
moral values such that intrinsically
it's good not to do this just because
full stop not because I'm being watched
this is an eye on the sky not because
I'll get rewarded later but because it's
just good would you prefer that people
work hard without getting paid well it
depends what they're doing another thing
a waiter it doesn't matter now factory
wykel EPU yeah exactly okay but but so
wait wait wait why is that why is that
less why in it because we're not moral
work is not morality it's a different
it's not that a different realm of
behavior oh you know I I'll never forget
it made a big impact on me before I got
married
32 some whole 20s I was a bachelor and I
knew nothing about marriage because
nobody knows anything about marriage so
you get married and and so I talk to
married men I'm a friend as a married
guy so he's a good-looking guy he was an
ex-marine television guy so I sent him
one day said Bob just curious we were
close enough did you ever cheat on your
wife and he said you know what that is
funny you should ask because obviously I
gotta know you know I'm tempted I travel
a lot it's tempting and he said you know
I'm not at all religious I you know I I
never I never go to church or synagogue
and but I got to tell you I know this is
going to sound funny gonna laugh at me
but I really do believe God is watching
and he said do not commit adultery I I
think that between for forgive me for
being as crass as it sounds between the
penis and the conscience the penis will
usually win and and and having God's
sake control your organ is is more
powerful you know I used to be in a band
in Brooklyn called between the penis and
the conscience were you there by you and
I was a we really a I was making an
illusion yeah but so jumping from that
to you basically because you you believe
that eventually will self-regulate
ourselves into into some goodness sort
of you think we could we could have the
laws of the land that we have right now
and we simply don't need the well then
if the founding fathers had some yeah
regardless of what the value about I
mean we've already been doing this for
centuries
you know the whole structure the whole
moral progress of Western civilization
that I've written about Steve Pinker is
written about so it comes about from
this idea that we can actually set up
political and economic and social
systems in a way it nudges people toward
being better and they I think Europe is
committing suicides have locally with
the God or and I'm just curious because
you mean because of the immigrant yes
yeah yes and because it no longer
believes in itself yes because all right
so that our opinion countries are based
on this in light now is like right human
at it yes the godless universe ceases to
believe in itself the Western world no
no Ben
the problem is these super religious
immigrants that are from know the
problem is the secular in allowing them
to get in not only allowing them to come
in they don't believe they don't believe
in anything anymore they believe in
vacation time in in maternity leave
higher wages that's what they believe
it's all material I think I think you
may also mean that they don't believe in
the goodness of the society that's our
cooking right exactly you would argue
comes from God you know I argue that a
will to live even to make babies the
religious affluent have far more babies
than the secular affluent there is a
massive this is why I said earlier I
came to God most particularly because I
saw the alternative doesn't work the
godless world being created in the West
in Western Europe his bait is is
dissipating the countries are literally
disappearing people don't even have the
will to marry or the will to have babies
or the will to preserve Britain or
Germany or France that's that that's a
loss so that's why I think that the
micro macro thing is the most
interesting part of this conversation
because again I don't think you think
that my truck can't in another way up
and with all your friends and family we
live it perfectly more life but do you
think there is something to that because
we're all what we are watching Europe
slowly crumble and I don't think anyone
knows exactly why I think I think that
is ultimately the research well I think
the universities are crumbled godless
wisdom I on an optimistic side yeah you
know most but I know a lot of Germans
now because my wife's from Cologne and
you know they're not just sitting around
going how can we get more welfare and
make more babies and get more you know
food style you know that's not what they
you vote they go to work like the rest
of us no no but that is what they sit
around thinking I just had a German my
student lived with us for six months he
he he described a Germany that I I
assumed and such as Germany could be
Belgium at this irrelevant that's what
that's what the materialist secular mind
thinks about is material it makes
perfect sense
more of it is now in the European
Constitution I believe how much vacation
time and oh it is now a human right to
travel but but they didn't even mention
in the European Constitution that
Christianity had formed Europe I'm a Jew
saying this but but but i but I care
about truth
Christianity made Europe without
Christianity you lose Europe that's the
way it is it but there's okay so you're
picking certain countries that maybe
Christianity had positive development
most Christian nations like all the
Catholic nations in South Americans on
they didn't develop all those civil
rights and equal treatment for women and
so like I'm talking area later than
Europe yeah so but I just like okay so
it's not religion it's something else
that's going on there well and my
argument is that it's these a like I'm a
legend it's good religion is a bad
religion and it's good for you to try
and your little trapdoor you're not a
trapdoor of course it's true what how
can I argue otherwise he would argue
this good atheism and bad atheism is
good secular and bad secular it's just
why can we be allowed that true there
are people who get it wrong there are
people who do not emphasize the Ten
Commandments they emphasize 55 other
things and they call themselves
religious what am I going to do I'm
unhappy about them but then how do you
know which is the better religion or the
less good religion what's the criteria
the same criteria that you would offer I
want to see your fruits yeah that's the
only thing that matters right and the
fruits of secular Europe is no more
Europe but yeah I don't think it's it's
the secular part I think there's other
factors though okay all right that's a
fair Thor difference of opinion I say
well since the Second World War they've
had a rather different history from
before for obvious reasons they're
killing each other less yes well they
had to do something to stop though I
agree well 1914 your idea they gave up
they gave up they threw the baby out
with the bathwater they threw out
nationalism and religion but so to sort
of pull back a little bit again we're
talking about what criteria are we using
the judge right and wrong okay so when
you say well it's religion Christianity
and I point out well what about all
those Catholic countries that's the
wrong person no no first of all I mean
when all is said and done if
I have to compare a catholic uruguay to
to a pre catholic uruguay
I'll take Catholic Uruguay you you you
have to believe their or you know take
the Mayans I think you believe that in
Mexico it was a step up for Mexicans to
Catholicism from Mayan ISM maybe in
maybe alright so let's get out of sort
of the the real world politic of this
and we'll go a little to a slightly
higher dimension here if we can for a
moment so if God handed us these Ten
Commandments and made all these strong
arguments wouldn't there just be less
pain I mean I know this is sort of a
nice and easy one and you've written
some books on this kind of thing in them
as a Michael but it wouldn't there just
be less it seems like there's are plenty
of religious people that do all sorts of
bad things in the name of religion it
shows you the power you're right but I
don't know anybody who starts betting to
the name of the Ten Commandments which
is where I really focus much of my
religious belief on but yes look who it
the the that I that is why I don't want
to get it I don't want to bore everybody
but that is why there is only one of the
ten commandments that God says he will
not forgive and that is doing evil in
his name people call it taking God's
name in vain but that's what it really
means the Hebrews do not carry not do
not take because of exactly your
questions and your points nothing ruins
the possibility of God based ethics as
much as people who do unethical in the
name of God they that is that you know
who do you know that this is unreported
much there are more atheist kids in Iran
today than in the history of the Muslim
world the ayatollahs are creating more
atheists than every atheist activist on
steroids okay that makes perfect sense
so we would argue that the beautiful
thing i between a secular iranian and
and I had totally irani and I'll take a
secular any day I told you the fruits
what about
on matter to me uh I'm your fruit
oriented I'm fruit or what is what is
the tree producing I'm saying a godless
tree will ultimately not produce a good
world but I rather have a good godless
person than a bad god person yeah is
that is that sort of the irony is that
in a weird way it had the secular person
or the non-believer needs a little bit
of sort of the crazy religious stuff in
this case the Ayatollah - actually that
makes it easier to breed some of the
things that you get rather than Michael
Shermer showing up in Tehran and going
guys you know I'm not going to try right
it takes it - no it's awesome Arabia but
is that yet if I write lately and yeah I
think I think that is why by the way
parenthetically I am very disappointed
in in the Western religious world there
should have been a hundred thousand
rabbis priests and ministers gather in
Washington or London or I don't care
where as a protest against all the evil
done in God's name in the world today
they have sat on the sidelines
intimidated by the New York Times which
would call them Islamophobic they are
more they have more fear of the New York
Times and fear of God I would say that
is a general assessment of most
religious people Jew and Christian in
the world today
maybe we should organize a joint atheism
secularism
we should and and we don't end out that
is exactly right and I don't care so
because we're not Islamophobes
yeah no no we're evil remotes yeah man
so I'm glad we got there because look we
could do this for hours and hours we've
got about an hour already right so first
off before I kind of get us toward the
final part did we miss any I know we
could dissect each video no no we win
anyway it was exactly what I imagined it
was wonderful discussion is there
anything any headway that I might have
well yeah I mean these are the great
issues of all time you know and the fact
that they're not ultimately resolvable I
think hints at how difficult they are in
term you know the big questions is there
a god freewill determinism you know
moral right and wrong good and evil you
know the fact that we don't have
universal agreement on it like a law of
physics that you can measure everywhere
tells us these are hard problems which
is why the only way
to figure out what to do is to talk to
other people especially those who don't
agree with you because if you're in the
echo chamber you're only going to hear
which is you just wasting your time
so how do we put that into practice
because I try to talk to people from all
over the political map and I have here I
have two people who view what it you
know perhaps the biggest issue of all
time in a very different way and I have
equal respect for both of you and what I
what I the question I get from people
all the time is well what do we do now
because I do think people think as you
said Western Europe is crumbling I think
people think the underpinnings of
America for resilience are the people
are people that fear Trump the people
that fear the media like oh whatever
corner you're in but here we've had a
you know the fear of Trump is irrational
okay it's just irrational I mean we're
not here for politics i but you raised
it i just want to say you didn't have to
vote from you don't have to support him
but the this there is a hysteria like
Russian collusion it was all hysteria
like he foment anti-semitism it was all
history you know who called in 90% of
the hundreds of threats to Jewish
community centers an American Jewish kid
living in Israel and the others that he
didn't call in were called in by a black
radical who wanted to frame his
ex-girlfriend no no it's all over don't
nobody talks now about all the same size
emeth ism in America because of Trump
you know it's very men today they do lie
when that was happening I actually
purposely didn't tweet about it because
I saw everyone getting on board and
telling it all Trump it's all Trump and
everything this just seems too easy I
want to wait a little bit and then of
course you end up right so how do we
take this yeah how do we take the
richness of this and go all right we
fundamentally believe something so
different but we actually still want to
live in the same society yeah because I
don't think you guys are going well you
know even if you think that the ideas
that Michael is pushed here aren't going
to be good in the long run for your
society or you think that your allies in
the cause of Liberty and that's about
what I want that's where I wanted
liberty and freedom of speech is on is
the fundamental right that trumps all
the other well Trump's it's the basis
that's beneath all the other stuff we're
talking about and obviously need
interesting that you both can get there
yeah absolutely
encouraged by that and as well as I'm
not sure what what you call what you're
doing alternative media to the
mainstream media or you know the
Internet media I'm always something
different in every universe that I'm
doing I don't know what the right word
is but I'm really encouraged with shows
like yours Joe Rogan's Sam Harris you
know and these are great shows I mean
the most interesting conversations that
I listen to are they're not you know on
CNN or whatever no these are this is
where it's at and that this could be the
future it where even academics who are
you know who are seemingly hopelessly
lost here will see like this Jordan
Peterson you know you can make more
money on patreon than from the universe
maybe that's the futures like just
talking to people like well look I know
Prager University we tell people get a
free education we will have 400 million
views this year right and the greatest
single percentage is under 35 years of
age whoa all right so then I have one
final question for you both what would
you be your greatest sell if someone
that's listening to that that is an
atheist they've just come to that
conclusion and if they didn't want to be
not convinced they don't want you to
convince them to not but they want to be
convinced of wanting to live in the same
society as you what's the great well I
gave the argument earlier the founders
did understand that without God it's a
limited government won't work just as
you said we've seen - that was an area
of agreement it seemed to me and I don't
want to put any words in your mouth god
forbid but III they understood if people
feel morally accountable to God then
they don't we don't need a lot of police
we don't need a big government
government rises in the West as as God
diminishes in the West and and in the
United States or in Europe because
somebody's got a police people
somebody's got to dictate what happens
the government substitutes I don't want
big government and the the American
dream was to have limited government so
that we are free
but ultimately morally answerable to the
God of the Ten Commandments that's
clever because he's playing to the
classical liberals as we know here a
work what would you be yourself or the
person that's a believer that's watching
this yeah but you'd want to live in that
same society yeah well I I think dr.
King had it right the the arc of the
moral universe is long but it bends
towards justice
I think the origin of the bending force
has been this inculcating in all of our
thinking to make it our second nature to
be good for goodness sake full stop now
we're a long ways from that you know
getting there but we're better than we
were half a century ago better still
than a century ago and so I do think
there's and I think that moral arc is
built into the structure of society the
way we keep tweaking it it's like an
experiment and I think we need to keep
running the experiment and that open
free dialog and speech is the only way
to keep tweaking it in the right
direction
well this has been an absolute pleasure
for me so I hope you guys have enjoyed
it oh and you both agreed took us a
while to get the schedules lined up
because you guys are busy but I'm glad
we did this and I hope we can do
something like this again we can figure
out some other existential things do a
great job crack you really do I can I
want to turn this way a little here you
know what and I have no reason to
patronize you with but so I'm not but
you your questions events sincere
curiosity and that's a big deal
strangely I think doing something that
should be common these it should be that
well thank you for that you for coming
in and thank you guys for watching and
yes we are going to do more of these
I've got a couple of interesting ones
lined up so it's yeah you know it's
youtube.com slash room where you're
watching this right now so anything you
say that thank you
[Music]